three welcome back to the lab where we
take your questions and turn them into
experiments my name is Mitch and I'm
Greg and today we're going to get 3d
printed for the past half decade 3d
printing has been predicted as the next
revolution in manufacturing from day to
day objects to our food to our organs
last year as 3d printed here not only
stayed alive but it actually grew it
works a lot like your printer that
prints ink on a page but instead of
printing one layer on and it's stacked
multiple layers upon each other to build
complex structures it's like making
sliced bread but in Reverse after
putting one layer down another is built
on top of that and so on until the whole
loaf of bread or your 3d printed object
is put together 3d printing can do a lot
of amazing things including 3d printing
and yourselves and ourselves so we're
going to head over to my 3d in Toronto
to do exactly that wow this is what
we're going to become what's the first
thing we got to do to 30min ourselves
first and foremost you definitely have
some tables hold mine 3d uses a
structured light 3d scanner that works
at 16 frames per second and captures 2
million points of information every
second it works by projecting a known
pattern onto an unknown object in this
case our bodies and then analyzes the
deformation and distortion of that
pattern to figure out how far different
points are from the scanner by using
triangulation for example if we project
a known pattern of parallel straight
lines onto a human body computers can
then calculate what the deformity is and
ultimately figure out what the shape of
that body is itself immediately we can
see pieces of our 3d image on the screen
as the program digitally reconstructed
the real world up in real time our
images need to be fully reconstructed
and touched up by an artist so I went
back to actually get our figurines and
sees some of them come right out of the
3d printer so here is the final
rendering of my 3d image before it was
printed this is called the 3d mesh and
it is looked over for any fragile points
that could
we break in the process like my arm
holding the phone the textures are then
added on to show what the final image
will look like our 3d models are going
to be printed on something called gypsum
or polymer clay it is laid out in
flattened layer by layer and made hard
when it is printed to binder and color
the print will take a few hours to
complete when it's done the excess
powder isn't vacuumed out and recycled
for future use and what's left over is
the print there we are the finishing
touches include blowing the remaining
powder off dusting it some more a thin
layer of glue is unapplied which keeps
the print hard and makes the color pop
are you ready yeah it's going to look
good don't miss it oh there is ha ha it
is then dipped in a wax finish mitch
getting a back massage ok so we've
gotten our 3d print so we're going to go
back to the lab or an open amount and
we're going to take a look over the
first time I've kind of seen my little
figurines but you haven't seen oh I have
no idea would look well now an unboxing
youtube channel so try to see what we
look like a miniature 3d this is going
to be if we were ever to be in a block
question have a little action taking me
way 2023 wah wah oh my god so cool I
look like an owl like I look like I'm
from Laurel right like that
doggy feels really like good I love it
it can like see anyway I think patterns
on the fabric that I've been like
chiseled yeah oh my god you're gonna
look up my oh you're Gabe some Bob yeah
Oh your father died causes yeah Greg's
like on his phone and huge I actually
stood with even as a little detail on
the phone is actually like so very cool
we've been immortalized so the concept
of 3d printing is fascinating and it has
so many applications there's a long ways
to go before I think it comes to our
home someone use all the time but this
is happening right now and so this is
really cool yeah we want to thank my 3d
agency obviously for letting us come and
get these down there in Toronto we'll
put links in the description you can
check
I'm out otherwise yeah try it out it's a
cool little keepsake to have a fun
little exercise otherwise we'll see you
in next time for the next experiment